hey is that a gun in your holster you're
happy to see me
i saw a video a few years ago from vice
and another from tom scott where they
went around london breaking weird
antiquated laws and i thought to myself
new york probably has some pretty dumb
laws i was right about that and after
doing a bit of research i decided to
come out here in new york city and break
as many dumb laws as i can in a day
[Music]
yes
[Music]
anyone want to buy some dog fur
it's ethically sourced would you like to
buy some dog fur it's just a dollar sir
you look like a man on the go that might
need some dog fur would you like to buy
some dog fur
okay okay my sales tactics aren't
working so far i'm gonna cut my prices
good how are you
it's a public space and you can't really
stand and
sell stuff ah
but it's just ten cents so if i stand
outside of the market that i'm okay i'll
go slightly outside of the market my
prices were too low they couldn't
compete would you like to buy some dog
fur go over there before they told me i
couldn't be in the market do you want
some no honey i got a dog at home doing
some type of uh project i'm trying to be
make it as i'm new york's next great dog
first salesman okay that's kind of weird
you know they're right yeah i have two
bags here this could make me 20 cents
i might buy a gumball
all the experience of having a dog
without having to own a dog would either
of you guys like to buy some dog fur for
10 cents or a nickel or even a penny if
you have a penny on you i will sell you
this dog for gonna ask that bald man if
he wanted any fur for his head but i
thought that might have been rude i'm
trying to sell this dog for for a cent
once
do you have any money on you i will take
any amount of money well i got one time
for you a dime that's that's what i was
selling it for before
here you go
that is a bag of dog fur see that
capitalism right there
find a product
find a buyer
[Music]
i cry a lot in the bathroom
helps me get through the day
it is apparently illegal to throw a ball
at someone's head for pleasure so we
gotta make sure that i look like i'm
having fun while i'm doing this dj you
ready
if i don't have fun i'm gonna have to do
it again
i don't think that was fun enough
that was more fun all right wait one
more one more time i gotta i gotta
really be sure i'm doing this for
pleasure and not just out of obligation
are you okay
and i had fun
so
i would say
success so far i have not been arrested
i haven't even seen a police officer
what are they doing
committing brutality
[Music]
apparently you're not allowed to roll
out a red carpet without a permit here
in new york um so we're gonna put that
to the test and what's the point of
rolling out a red carpet unless you have
a show to put on and so my lovely
assistant dj here has a window in which
i'm gonna put a puppet show on which is
apparently also illegal sesame street be
warned
[Music]
oh look at that and i gotta prepare my
sock puppets oh wow it is great to be
here in new york city i hope i see some
celebrities is that dwayne the sock
johnson would you like to go to a show
yeah i was about to go to the socky
horror picture show seymour's your
friend
well that was pretty good
you should be on sockway which is what
socks called broadway for some reason
would you like to be my best friend
dwayne the sock johnson
yeah i'll do it
and
scene
hey
you see this shirt
you wanna know what it's made of
boyfriend material
thank you
you know i i didn't see any stars in the
sky last night because all the heavenly
bodies are right here
hey
how you doing
is this your mom
i was gonna say you uh you must been
birthed by an angel but that would
undersell
it hey is that a gun in your holster you
happy to see me
it is apparently illegal to wear
slippers after 10 p.m in new york city
so i'm out here wearing some slippers
and you may you may notice this ice
cream cone i've got in my hand well it's
also illegal on sundays to put an ice
cream cone in your pocket and it is
currently 10 25 p.m on sunday august
15th
and i'm about to walk in front of the
police that's what i call crime
think i got away with it that was
nerve-wracking
i wanted to flirt with a cop here in
union square because i thought that was
the best chance of me getting in trouble
but we walked around the square and
couldn't find a single police officer
since i haven't gotten in trouble today
it just goes to show me that these laws
are not enforced and that the police
truly aren't doing their jobs but who
could have seen that coming at least i
got 10 cents out of it so for me it was
a win
[Music]